i'm just really um happy that you're
willing to come away from the table
um
i'm like nervous now and i'm never
nervous i feel nervous don't be nervous
i know i'm nervous because i really want
to show who i am and i'm nervous to show
you and tell you what i'm feeling
take care i'm going to have to speak
right okay
i see how you are with all the other
women and i and i see how you're
fun-loving generous you have a great
heart and i really regret that i didn't
get to know you and it's the last night
you know i'm trying to analyze what's
going on here i have to figure out like
what what is about me you know that like
triggers people like i triggered you
i regret that because i didn't want to
trick you i really wanted to get to know
you
well you know i appreciate you opening
up to me now and feeling bad about it
that means a lot but
because we are at the end of our trip
you know
um
i was scared you're not afraid to speak
your mind
i was like scared to say to you
something because i thought like maybe
you'd attack me okay so she's playing
the victim card again
tread very carefully i was nervous okay
i was nervous i was amazed but you
weren't afraid to call me a [ __ ]
you got to be honest no
somehow you triggered something within
me
wasn't maybe you was something within me
that made me react and i don't know why
i reacted the way i did because i don't
normally say that to someone i don't
know you know for me it was like a slap
in my face because i'm like well i was
trying you know i'm not that person
that's what i'm trying to say
i'm upset with myself how i butted heads
with you
what do you think is going on i know i
mean i'm taking them well i like that
it's taking a while because if it was
too quick that's not good kyle and i
were talking to her today and she's like
i always wanted to get to know kenya and
i just got off on the wrong foot wow
right she teared up yeah she did real
cheers
really no they were
you were the person i really knew the
least and i really wanted to get to know
you
and one of the things i wanted to kind
of like share on the side with you if
you wanted to talk about it was that you
know you and i have a little bit of
similar backgrounds growing up because
you had a mother who you know wasn't
there for you and even though my father
was in my home physically i got no love
from him either
i don't know your whole story which is
the things that you've shared i think
that we could possibly connect on those
things
my
mom she has never acknowledged me my
whole life oh my god
hello
hi
she's done this before oh i haven't done
this a million times you know it's a
waste of time
i heard you locked the door
she gave me to my grandmother she signed
the papers she asked her would you write
that
she never named me she didn't want to
have anything to do with me
we learn love from our parents your
mother teaches you how to love and then
the father teaches you how to love
another man so i had a very difficult
time finding relationships i would pick
men
that wouldn't connect yeah and
emotionally unavailable is the same
thing that i do now and that's why i'm
in the situation with my husband through
therapy i learned that yeah that is a
direct correlation on my mother's
situation because she was never
emotionally available to me jerk
portobello
oh i'll try it yeah
thank you honey you're welcome i have a
question i want to ask everybody this is
the one i've been wanting to ask the
most really did you have a misconception
about people then all of a sudden you
feel totally different about or not
really kenya
you know because people kept saying
she's a drama queen literally like all
of you asked me about her
everybody called me i was like what
about kenya i am a very forgiving person
i don't really hold on to grudges when
people are accountable for their actions
i actually respect that more than
anything else
i won't hold a grudge against you i
appreciate that no i won't i promise you
the only thing that would bring us
backwards if the same behavior shows
itself again
no one is perfect but you have to show
that you're growing not going berserk on
the plane on you for me that was a lot
of growth
thank you for that
i'm so serious i'm really glad that ken
and i had this conversation and i feel
like we both have come to understand
each other better and can build a
friendship
i think what you need to is a hug
you know i do need help oh my god thank
you
okay sometimes oh my gosh thank you
kenya
thank you for this time
you're okay you're gonna be okay
there's a lack of love in ramona's life
she's seeking attention any way that she
can get it i'm starting to
peel back the layer and to see who
really
is ramona i mean that feels really good
because the path to any friendship is
common
ground beautiful
feel it can you feel it